James arenda stepped down as the
Director of Nevada prisons in 2019 but
on Monday he'll be back and this is
after a lot of turmoil at the Nevada
Department of Corrections zoranda served
as the Director from 2016 to 2019 under
the leadership of Republican Governor
Brian Sandoval most recently zarenda was
the Nassau County sheriff in New York
that's on Long Island in a statement to
the eight news now investigators he
writes he's honored and excited to
return thankful that Governor Lombardo
is bringing him back and calls this
quote a time where it is crucial to
bring back the importance of Public
Safety and reduce Community
victimization by raising the standards
in the correctional system one priority
of his will be to address staffing
issues inside prisons a challenge he
faced the first time he held the job and
here's an interview we did in 2016.
people need to see that our number one
priority outside of Safety and Security
is try to do the best we could for
offenders because they're going to be
going home within the past year the
eight news now investigators have
uncovered major problems inside Nevada
prisons including a riot which the
department tried to downplay inmate
murders and suicides and The Escape of a
convicted murderer that was followed by
director Charles Daniels stepping down
and then his battle with the office of
Governor Steve sisalak surrender knows
he has his work cut out for him he does
have the support of return strong that's
a group which advocates for better
conditions inside Nevada prisons Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now